all right so what we're calling this
enabling conditions hypothesis i did
send you an op-ed that was published i
think about two years ago in a newspaper
in bangladesh neither necessary not
sufficient
so this is what the idea was neither
necessary not sufficient three enabling
conditions for effective transboundary
water management
so i started with this idea that does
life cause death does oxygen cause fire
does rain cause flood
what it means essentially then if you
look at these three questions going from
very philosophical point of view that
life caused death of course you need
life before you can die
just because if you are not alive you
cannot die so
but does it cause it
a same thing with oxygen really oxygen
does it cause fire
why is this important because right now
i'm sitting in my room i have oxygen
but there is no fire
but think about a situation really about
maybe five thousand years ago when we
did not know about all of this
and we had lot of fire in many different
places
there you are a scientist scientifically
minded individual you went and measured
everywhere and you find that in every
place there is a fire there is oxygen
so then you have a theory now
that theory tells you oxygen cause fire
it's a good theory because i don't think
basically think about it like 5000 years
ago i did not know any of this chemistry
i did not know oxygen
but i found out certain things are
present in all situations when there is
fire
so now i am basically very brilliant i
came up with a theory oxygen caused fire
so this is the fundamental problem of
cause and effect or observing certain
things
by observing certain other things and
trying to link them
so what i argue that this is really
fundamentally what scientific methods
are all about you take observations then
you formulate a hypothesis and then you
test it and then you refine it
so now if you are 5000 years ago then
how do you know that oxygen is not
causing the fire
what do you have to do
this is where this idea of necessary
sufficient conditions become extremely
problematic
in this particular case now you know
that
like for example in my room right now
i'm sitting here there is oxygen but
there's no fire
so that means why it's not there
so you may see oxygen is necessary
but not sufficient
what is sufficient then you need to have
some trigger
if you have a trigger
then it will start fires if you now
start basically put some
fire here with you maybe with a candle
or something that means my house may get
into fire
so that's the distinction you need to
make say but this is right now may seem
very obvious
but when you get into the
messiness of say transboundary water
management or other complex problems
there are many many causes can create an
outcome
many many causes can create something
that you see
so far that what you see
then you try to attribute some cause
and then you get into this idea of
necessary and sufficient conditions
what we are arguing really in complexity
that no
in complexity
problems or the problems which are
complex but many many
variables and actors and institutions
are interacting with each other
you simply cannot isolate
cause and effect very cleanly
there are causes of course
but those are not easily identifiable
as a result you get into trouble
what happens really you may identify
something as cause
then very quickly you find out that is
not the case
and you are seeing this with covet 19
over the last 14 months
we have attributed to many many things
as a causal condition then later on we
found out that may not be and we even
found out that all kinds of solutions
starting from using bleach
from our president but these are all
essentially
just trying to relate some arbitrarily
linked
things and in a simplest case people
would say that there are some
correlation maybe
and you know the correlation is not
causation but that's we said this is
very cliche we're not interested
we are fundamentally challenging this
idea of cause and effect
that you simply cannot identify cause
and effect very cleanly as you can in
some other cases even in the simplest
case does rain cause flood
and one of you said yes
yes it does in some in most cases it
does but in many cases it will not
so think of really in boston it was not
raining for last several days now if it
rains one inch there'll be no flood
because
most of the water will essentially
infiltrate and go to the ground
now if it rains for three days in a row
yes that basically soil will get
saturated you'll get flood
so that means you need some conditions
so here rain is a necessary condition
but it's not a sufficient condition
the problem of this type of analysis
really came if you go back now what is
this idea of necessary and sufficient
gain
so i did dig basically deeper into this
it came from geometry
in geometry it is very precise because i
need to have four sides to have a
rectangle
and with 90 degree angle i need to have
three sides to have a triangle there is
no way around it
so i can explicitly say what are the
necessary and sufficient conditions for
something to be considered a triangle
that is not the case
for many physical systems
more importantly many couple systems
like where you have natural systems and
human systems
like our transparent water problem but
you have natural systems so water is
getting coupled with the human systems
of managing getting governing it when
they're coupled the systems become
complex this notion of necessary and
sufficient conditions are not good
enough
so i'll stop here just to give you a
pause see what you think about this
distinction between necessary sufficient
conditions then we'll go into enabling
conditions
i presume we don't have to wait 5 000
years
to make judgments
about such things
um
and i'm i'm interested in
how you think
we know
enough
to say
that's only correlation that's not
causation
yeah and and is it really could it be a
function of time and perspective and
experience and that there's not really a
method to know
that quickly
yeah so yeah we'll get into something
basically
i did not have a chance to discuss this
with you so we are basically making
distinctions now to between two types of
facts and this is part of the discussion
that we have today
so one thing that over time that we have
learned this idea of scientific method
and scientific facts
another thing that basically we are
pointing and it has been used in social
science for quite some time called
social facts
and we are making a sharper distinction
between these two right now
so
what i argue really in this particular
case that scientific facts are basically
a particular type of facts those facts
are verifiable
reproducible
replicable
those will not depend on really
perspective or notion they may depend on
methods over time but there is a way to
get around this that's the whole idea of
scientific methods we'll talk about that
social fact on the other hand does not
have to be true
does not even have to be verifiable it
just we believe
it's just that we accept it as reality
and that is fine too and we have done
many of this for example this whole idea
of
currency
is a social fact
we give tremendous amount of value now
to this something green called dollar
and whether i'm in bangladesh or in
boston doesn't matter everybody accepts
it whether they believe in me whether i
am a
atheist or i am agnostic or i am a
muslim does not matter
you accepted that this is something that
everybody thinks is good and now think
about what is happening with iranian
currency it has been significantly
devalued because of all this embargo
that we have created so that
is really a paper
and that paper has certain value because
everybody in the world thinks a dollar
is very valuable
it's a social fact and there is no way
to justify whether this is true or not
it is true right now i can use it
anywhere i want
but i do not know what will happen to
this daily 10 years from now
so those are the distinctions we need to
make and we will make those distinction
when we are talking about scientific
fact and social effect in this
particular case of your
fire
can be
basically determined by scientific
method
because what can we do really even 5000
years we didn't have to go that far we
can find out really
that although oxygen is necessary
it does not create fire everywhere so
that means something else has to happen
so that is a systematic way of doing
experiments and then to find that out
but i have seen few places that where
there is fire there is oxygen
so my immediate conclusion could be that
oxygen causes fire
then that has to be questioned and
refined over time
so let's go with this enabling so what
we are saying here that we need three
enabling conditions and i was careful
really not to use this idea of necessary
and sufficient anymore so three enabling
conditions are needed for any boundary
crossing complex water agreement
to be initiated implemented and
sustained so this is a very big claim
we're making here
so whether you are working with indus
treaty or you are working with ganges
what we are saying that master of if you
want to be basically writing your
ganges treaty for 2026 yeah we want to
do it
we need to be very careful about these
three conditions
you may say no i need something else
then we'll talk about this
but what i am saying that at least these
three are needed
so what are these three
the first one is this has to be an
active recognition of interdependencies
meaning that if you need to sign a
gangest city between india and
bangladesh they have to actively
recognize interdependencies
india has to recognize that bangladesh
exists and they need them just saying
that because india is upstream
bangladesh is downstream of course there
is already different interdependency
there
but that's not good enough
what is happening right now if you think
about it like animation we worked on a
little bit with brahmaputra
brahmaputra is creating serious problem
between china and india
but there is no active recognition right
now
china india although they are
independently saying that yeah you are
using our water and we are in serious
trouble but they have never
so far actively recognized this
as a result really what we argued that
no i don't think they are going to go to
any treaty and they are not right now
although there is a lot of noise a lot
of discussion a lot of international
forum international funding agency
trying to find out what is going on
brahmaputra
what i am arguing that i am yet to see
anything that is tangible happening in
the brahmaputra
so if you have to ask me although these
are dangerous game to play in terms of
prediction
there would not be a brahmaputra treaty
signed
unless
this recognition is active
between china and india
and that is exactly what happened if you
look at indus water treaty indus water
treaty was signed in 1960 between
pakistan and india because they actively
recognized that this is important
about the same time
president johnson from the u.s sent
another envoy to israel and palestine
to have jordan treaty
jordan treaty was not signed until 1994.
so why that one was signed in 1960
another was in 1994. in both cases
u.s
was a basically
a significant player
so you need to think about those really
then i say yeah look at that time they
did not recognize
jordan did not recognize register is
important or vice versa
so as a result it took a long time
in 1994 they came and basically they
signed the peace treaty part of that was
a water treaty too
so just think about those two cases
between indus and jordan
then you get some to really want this
enabling condition one means
second one is that i'm sure you have
talked about this mutual value creation
so just because you have recognized the
problem and you have a conflict is not
good enough now now you have to see
really can you create some mutual value
through negotiation that both party will
benefit
because otherwise you you have limited
amount of water
and you have no way to divide this and
your actual need is much more than what
is actually available then how do you
get around this
so only way then you can get around this
even creates a mutual value and then you
can do it many different ways i'm sure
lady and animesh has given you ideas of
really how to create mutual values how
do you connect different type of sectors
and different resources and so on it
doesn't you don't have to talk about
water only you can bring in food you can
bring in energy you can bring in
security you can bring in military power
all kinds of things can be done yeah so
to
discuss these things um
if we consider this uh ganza's example
uh we already heard the ganza's treaty
but in my view this mutual value
creation
didn't happen until now so
uh
but already the tt has been signed so
what do you say about that this
although this enabling condition
didn't
meet but there is a treaty or
a
negotiation
now you see here we say they initially
implemented and sustained
yeah so yes you can have it because you
have it for there were some basically
all the mutual value fully was not done
but it was done partly there were
certain things done for example
bangladesh could have told
india that look
if we want to have this treaty now we
want you on transit we'll give you
transit
see india want to transit yearly from
basically to go through bangladesh
so if they want to do this then let's do
this the bangladesh is trying to do this
ganges barrage now
so for ganges bras india may get flooded
little bit
can that be brought into the picture
so the issue is that basically you have
to bring in other issues those are now
basically being discussed in bangladesh
right now if you think about like what
is the particular problem with the
ganges ganges is not a problem for the
flood season
the problem is really the dry season so
in the dry season the flow goes down so
low
that we have a serious basically issues
of water shortage so take a hypothetical
example if you take the entire water
basically during the dry season it's
about 4000 qm
still it will not be good enough to keep
the calcutta port navigable one of the
primary reason that india wanted to
build the farakka barrage was to keep
calcutta fort navigable
but in the dry season the flow goes so
low
it still cannot even they have taken all
the water so that means they have to
come up with alternative sources can
they use groundwater
can this basically store water during
the flood season over extended period of
the river that is what bangladesh
proposed in the ganges barrage
this is like a over 50 mile
river that will be
using as a storage device because
bangladesh is a very flat country we
cannot create another dam
so that's another mutual
mutual value creation option can be
explored
let me ask a question professor please
so you said something very interesting
that i'm creating mutual values and from
from where i understood i might be wrong
that anything goes
so one of the uh
one of the tension between bangladesh
and india
is bangladesh being used
uh as a as a vessel to create trouble in
its uh seven sisters
so which is why like it is of india's
interest to maintain the security in
bangladesh so i'm wondering like if if
that sort of
value can be created even
i mean can this be used as a bargaining
chip so that is what i want to
know
definitely yes i'll tell you something
that is i think you hit it exactly right
so about three years ago when we have
our water diplomacy workshop and then
you may remember
we have
four individuals from bangladesh foreign
ministry came
from foreign ministry to really to learn
about water diplomacy in our workshop
and their primary concern was that they
want to work on the water treaty what
would they do so we discussed the seven
sisters issue
and we discussed that this is an issue
that yeah this is a security problem for
india
can that be used that bangladesh will
create opportunity for that so that
these insurgencies do not go
for india yes this is open for
discussion
you can link that with basically water
in that case so i can actually bring
security where i work
yes you can you can and definitely and
this is a relevant problem
for for india to basically keep taking
care of those seven sisters and this
insurgency is a serious security problem
and bangladesh can help
and also bangladesh can be used as a
transit
but then bangladesh has to find us
something else in return
that is where the discussion must go on
this is the discussion i had with the
foreign minister even after that i went
to bangladesh and we did have a workshop
on water diplomacy within the foreign
basically ministry and
then pandemic started of course then we
got stuck
the difficulty i'll tell you this is
just not to be shared with bangladesh
government so i think the difficulty
that we have
in bangladesh in
many of these ministries are extremely i
think i would say progressive but
there is no system memory
meaning that water secretary is water
secretary right now suddenly he gets
transferred to transportation
that memory doesn't exist that basically
he initiated certain things and that
does not continue to the next secretary
so as a result really you reinvent
everything every time
and that's a problem
i mean lack of
memory is like it's it's a serious issue
in developing countries like bangladesh
uh i completely agree i vote for the
components i understand
so that's a different problem so that's
why we'll go later baby so the third one
that we are saying this adaptive regime
of governance and that is also very
important because you need to anticipate
i think
you are saying that yes in industry
there was no climate change mentioned
because in 1960 we did not know even
climate existed that is not climate
change
so we have no idea about this so but
they did not put any probation but they
did put some other provision though
if you look at the industry they had a
technical provision that they said that
if there is a technical problem that
pakistan and india cannot resolve
somebody else should come into the
picture
you know what that somebody else was
i have mentioned it already oh you did
okay
all right so
so that was brilliant
that was brilliant
the question is basically why the mit
president has to be basically
somebody has to come in and then appoint
a body because they thought mit is a
good technical institution they may
still exist for 50 60 years from now and
they will have no interest in india and
pakistan
so this was brilliant so when you are
trying to design this treaty for indus
or for the ganges you need to be also
thinking forward basically you don't
know what will happen whether climate
change will come what will happen is
another kobe 22 comes in who knows
but there has to be some provisions so
that this can be used
what we are arguing with this enabling
condition hypothesis is this
that these three if they are not in
place
ut is not going to be basically
implemented well it cannot be sustained
very well that's a big claim
so i want to
hear or maybe you can do it later as
well that
find out a treaty that was
initiated implemented and sustained for
a long period of time but one of these
conditions were missing
that would be good exercise
i could not find one yet
but are these going to guarantee success
no
they are not going to guarantee success
but they will be you can see these are
minimum subset
so one example i usually give to make it
simpler is that if you want to get a phd
what are the
enabling conditions
number one is obvious i think you have
to be alive
otherwise you cannot do it so fine
number two is that you need to have a
bachelor's
unless you're getting an honorary degree
we're not talking about honorary degree
if he's an earned phd
you need to have a bachelor so which
bestsellers i do not know it could be in
political science it could be in
ideology it could be in computer science
does not matter but you need to have a
bachelor's at least
everything
else
are situational you need to have an
advisor you need to have funding you
need to have a topic all kinds of things
will be needed and then of course you
have to pass the qualifying exam
a department has different requirements
you have to take this course that course
those i'll call those situational
conditions if fast to enabling
conditions are not there you'll not get
it
but just because you have those first
two dozen will that mean that you'll get
phd no
so that's what the difference is
so when you're thinking about this
really thinking along those lines so
these are not necessary and sufficient
conditions i'm not telling you what will
be necessary to get a phd what will be
sufficient to get a phd
but i'm just telling you that you need
this two enabling conditions
then you need many many situational
conditions
and those situation conditions are
context dependent
it will depend whether it is at mit or
tops or somewhere else or whether you're
in engineering versus in urban planning
they have different requirements
but then
what is the difference between necessary
condition and enabling condition
oh no necessary conditions does the
necessary conditions could be many
i'm telling you that you don't need more
than these three
i can come up with many necessary
conditions it may not still satisfy all
and see that's the reason i think see
which one is
the reason i think i want to get away
from this necessary and sufficient as we
mentioned this really came from a very
structured discipline called geometry
so
i'm trying to find solve a geometric
problem now i want to apply to my messy
transboundary water management problem
that's the reason i want to make the
distinction because here if you look at
the news and look at writings you'll see
that yeah this was not a necessary
condition we did not satisfy necessary
condition then you ask them okay so what
are the necessary conditions
so to give you a simple example i tell
you that i want to go from here to new
york
so what are the necessary and sufficient
conditions
can you exhaustively write this
no there would be thousands so it is not
possible to cover them all
you got it so this is basically a very
large space
i may decide to walk
i mean i decide to take a plane i'll
take a bike
i'll take a bike and then i will take a
boat
or i have a donkey
so i essentially cannot
exhaustively write down all the
conditions that's what the difficulty is
so that brings us to something else
really that i want to start maybe our
talk that so let's start
legal language sometimes
sometimes like try to
i mean make conditions that are
exhaustive for example
if the copyright of a chocolate
is asked by a lawyer then he would write
that this chocolates this chocolate has
to be from this particular
this particular tree and it cannot be
consumed by any other party
without paying the money to the
original company
in any form
so in this way they can probably i mean
minimize i don't know whether i could
make sense or not but legal language
sometimes tries to i mean cover all
those all those conditions that you say
that like there are so many conditions
sure
so this is where essentially now i think
you got it exactly right so this is what
basically although we don't want to talk
about our previous president so now
if you
come into the problem really if you want
to define really what the presidency
should entail
does president have to really
file taxes and make it clear this was
not explicit
it was not explicitly he has to file
taxes and make it public
so he decided not to do it now the
question is how many things can you
write down explicitly the president has
to do then i have to even tell you when
he goes to the bathroom this is what he
has to use
the problem is so this is exactly the
point so for for the presidency of the
united states
how many things you can explicitly write
what he or she do
or does really as a president we cannot
do this so we are assuming that certain
things they will do because
they are morally responsible individuals
i cannot be explicit about them
because if i make it explicit then it
becomes essentially rooting as you said
that yeah you can write it down this
particular chocolate cake from this
particular tree and this can be eaten by
only this particular individual
fine
but then how many of them you write
that is where essentially necessarily
sufficient conditions miserably failed
particularly in the system when those
are coupled
it can be fine right now we see like if
you have asked me the best law that we
have is newton's laws of gravity what is
it that basically apple fall
and apple was falling before newton
we just did not understand this he was
brilliant to find out a particular law
that applies everywhere right now
whether i'm in bangladesh or in boston
apple falls and i know that i can
explain it by gravity
so that's a law which is i would say the
physical law that is
replicable verifiable everywhere you go
now to take an example for water that i
use is that water flows usually downhill
because of the energy gradient
that's the physical law
but water also flows uphill
for example water flows uphill in the
american waste to money
in my home on the second floor because i
put a pump otherwise water cannot go to
my second floor
my gravity should go down how come how
could i get water in my second full
bathroom
i get it because the water is
pressurized so i can create conditions
that really the things can also violate
the physical laws
now when those physical laws are
violated by human intentions
then you have a problem
like for example genji's was flowing
fine
india decided to build a barrage
was not there
now they can control it
so there's a physical control of water
really which is violating the physical
principles
and that's where now your natural
systems and human systems are coupled
and then it becomes a complex problem
is it making sense
yes
all right
so here i think i'll give you a quiz and
then we'll continue so how many colors
do you see here
what a diplomacy a principal pregnancy
approach to government manage complex
societal problems
how many colors
three three good so remember three three
is important here then i will tell you
something else so
so what are
diplomacy
principle pragmatic
govern complex
problems so
put all kinds of words and i'm sure you
have heard many of these words many many
times in this class so how many colors
are here
seven
i mean good
so you have three and then you have
seven
so i'll just give you one basically clue
and then we'll discuss this at the end
of the class
so if you really want to be very
scientific about this
there are only three colors
rbg
red blue and green
then
[Music]
everywhere you go really this seven
color comes in
there there are seven colors of rainbow
there are seven heavens
there are all kinds of seven came into
the picture what is this three and seven
then came from i have only three color
why do i have seven
why do people say that there are seven
colors in rainbow
in reality if you go to the fundamental
color there are only three
now if you go to your computer really
and if you have a base in a
24-bit machine you probably have about
on the order of 8 million colors
based on these three combination of rbg
so i can go from three to eight million
and now if you just give your color
palette and i tell you that find it or
what color is this there is simply no
you can find it out unless i tell you
what those are
so what is my point here the point is
that you can take three things
and put it in different ways and you can
get millions of millions of combinations
same thing is true for this necessary
and sufficient conditions
i can take three
variables
or three
situations in a particular water
conflict
and arrange it in different ways
i can get many many combinations
so in this particular from three to
seven to millions
that is the case that means my necessary
and sufficient conditions will never be
able to be exhaustive i cannot do it
although fundamentally they are related
maybe to only three
but i cannot come to that three level if
i come to that three level is too
abstract
so that's why they put this basically
mambo jumbo stuff here they're basically
you want only 26 letters
but you can create a shakespeare to
water diplomacy book and everything else
in between by different combinations of
letters
that is exactly the point really with
these
interconnected systems
your building blocks may be very few but
the way those building blocks are
interconnected and interdependent may
create different situations and that has
serious implications really in what the
way we will think about water so let's
go there here so i'll start with this
many phases of water crisis
if you think about it really what is
water crisis
what is crisis really if you think about
you and they will tell you that if you
have 20 liters of water per person per
day from an improved source
you have access to water
that's the estimated definition and that
definition is used globally based on the
definition there are about 760 million
people who does not have access to water
so this is what we are trying to do with
this our sdg
now if you think about this this is
really not true the 760 million is not
true why is not true there are about 2
billion people lives in slums
across the globe from dhaka islam to
bombay slum to nairobi slums and
everywhere and from brazil and these
people
are not even counted
why are not the counter because most of
them are in illegal government land
so government does not provide them
water so they are not even counted they
don't have access to water or access it
doesn't matter
so who are these 760 million people
these people are essentially people in
rural villages in africa and asia
so these are one problem with water
access to water definition of water
crisis
on the other hand really when they talk
about water scarcity
they have a different definition what is
this this is fewer than thousand cubic
meter of water per person per year
so if you're in the u.s
if you have thousand cubic meter of
water per person per year you are not
water scarce so boston for example is
not water scarce
but nevada is
but as a whole us is not
that translate to
2740 liter per person per day
look at the difference between 20 and 2
740.
huge difference
do you have access to water versus are
you watered scared
these are two different things
and we often time get confused with you
what which one are you trying to address
if you go to sdg it's not clear what
they want to do
they have their thing is gold seven i
think is related to water and they have
all kinds of things there but it's so
i would say nebulous that it's not clear
exactly how they're going to measure
this and how they're going to implement
this
so
access to water is not necessarily
constant by availability
to water really it is something else
so when you want to talk about water
crisis
and your objective is to provide water
to islam in bangladesh is a very
different problem
than saying that i want to have water
for agriculture production in bangladesh
these are two different problems
and oftentimes we confuse them
and let's go to the next one
so what are the scientific facts that's
a societal problem here many more people
die from unsafe water than from all
forms of violence including war
so these are statistical facts
there are also economic analysis every
dollar invested in safe water and
sanitation yields anywhere between 5 to
27 in economic benefits
you don't have to agree with that 527 is
more than one dollar
will not go into the economic argument
here for now but at least there are many
many studies that have done this
that if i invest one dollar right now i
can get five to twenty seven dollars so
that means i can make more money still
not doing it
so what is the problem
and then i say okay 768 million people
like access to water 2 billion people
are living in high water scarcity region
so how come we are not doing anything
about this
and this is the statistics i had when i
was a graduate student many many years
ago
how could you have a crisis then you're
not resolving this crisis so that means
it's not a crisis
so why is not let's say that i am
generous i want to make 50 liters not
20. 50 per person per day
give me 120 billion dollar i can do it
for everywhere in the globe
look at the global gdp 85 trillion
dollars
only 0.14 percent of global gdp
so how come this is a global community
we're so much basically benevolent so
much generous you cannot spend even 0.14
percent of our gdp to
give water to everyone
so the problem is not economic then
problem is not that we don't have that
technology
so how do i go then so this is where i
think maybe we can be a little bit more
creative as water diplomats
that these are not really the argument
that people are making we need to make
different types of arguments
so then it comes really basically this
is the cover page of our book so we're
saying that look i think when you were
to look at this problem really you need
to look at this there are natural domain
problems there are societal domain
problem
these have been studied forever
but they also happen in a politically
real world
so one in water diplomacy what we are
arguing for last several years that look
you need to understand the natural
problem it comes the societal problem
you need to also understand that this is
happening in a politically real world
so how do i combine this scientific
knowledge and social knowledge in a
politically real world where
things will have some way to at least
have some traction
i don't have to discuss this idea of
really look i only need point one four
percent of gdp still people do not have
access to water 768 million people do
not have access to water these are all
known problems go to any water
literature right now any water crisis
you'll see this status is given
everywhere
so nothing is being done then
those are the type of questions we want
to raise and hopefully you guys will
have
some clue really when you are in your
organization to have some impact
so the reason i think what we argue that
is happening that there are
differences political boundaries
knowledge know-how management these are
all
basically happening at multiple scales
and these choices are particularly
problematic because they cross
boundaries
they have uncertainty they have
multiplicity of values so these are not
basically unknown
what we are basically hoping to do with
our water diplomacy framework is that we
want to explicitly recognize this and
see really how to at least adjust some
of it so that we can go
or we can be little bit better than what
we were yesterday
see i may not be here for another 30
years so i could not see this changing
very much in 30 years
in 30 years really we still had the same
number of people dying out of this lack
of sanitation and water across the globe
so are we basically dumb or we are just
too insensitive
so this is what essentially is we are
standing here and we in the present year
we came from past but we don't know
exactly where we came because past is
although came happened once
the interpretation of past could be
quite different really because for
example if you think about really how i
came where i am right now if you ask my
your my mother or my wife or my daughter
they will have different stories
and some of these stories will be
probably similar but it will not be
exactly the same so that means our
understanding of the past is also really
colored
by our own experience our own
perspectives and the way we have seen it
the problem even is that future could be
even more unknown because we have no
clue how it will happen
but only thing we have is passed
so how do i create what are management
situations really by looking at the past
knowing that future is unknown
so this is the fundamental puzzle it's a
scientific puzzle as well as social
puzzle
this is where you need to basically the
question where is okay in 1960 they
didn't know about climate change
i don't know what will happen next 50
years we did not know that copied 19
will come really in 2020
it indeed and it changed the life
significantly
so those are unknown
and then we need to have some way to
essentially deal with it what is the
next covet going to come we don't know
so what does that tell you
what tells you really the most of our
understanding really from science is
from physics
what physics tells us really that with
classical physics i can essentially
describe the world in a very
interesting and very predictable way
but the problem with complex system is
that they are not easily describable by
classical physics or quantum mechanics
say
world is not deterministic world is also
not random it is somewhere in between
that's what the complex system is
complex systems argues that this is not
a purely predictable system
at the same time it is not a random
system either
so everything that you've learned in
school now is really not becoming very
useful because everything you learn is
essentially either based on some
classical physics which is deterministic
equations or statistics
but we are arguing that the for complex
system now that will work
you need a combination of these two
then you come with this this basically
two scientists in 1973 they were telling
you the search for scientific basis for
confronting problems of social policy is
bound to fail
and this is a very classical paper
really written in 1973 cited over 10 000
times now so is this a wicked problem
yeah
so they were very brilliant two young
assistant professor from berkeley in
1973
so
what they were telling me that when you
are confronted with complex problems we
don't talk we get because we can't i
don't like this word but they use wicked
but we can essentially in their term is
very similar to what we call complex and
these are interconnected problems these
are interdependent problems there is
simply no way to do cause and effect and
particularly when there are social
policy involved
then came this lady really from here
wellesley she was an economics professor
and a chair she said you can't take
politics out of this analysis
now you have three things you have
physical systems your social system your
political systems
and what we argue in what are diplomacy
we try to mix them up
and we said that all three are important
you need to be careful about all three
you just cannot pick one or the other
and then your solution is not going to
be very sustainable
so uh here how is the difference between
the social system and the political
system sometimes
yeah so okay so yeah so then you have to
go yeah
that is a good point
you have to go then to our diagram here
let me see you can go back here
so so
i did not do so i said societal so
societal we are saying that there are
only three things because we want to
make life simpler we said we put
governance assets as norms and values as
societal we are keeping political as a
different entity so this separation in
many places you may find to be not
really that clean you can put politics
also in societal domain that will be
fine but then you need to be explicit
but here we are explicit we are saying
that for us when we talk about natural
systems we are talking about quality
quantity and ecosystems
measurable quantifiable
more or less
when we talk about societal systems we
talk about governance and we are keeping
it broad governance could be your
ngo to your government to
basically your
water board in pakistan or bangladesh
norms and values could be also quite
broad
it could be your cultural values it
could be religious values of waters we
are keeping them broad assets is not
only money it could be human assets too
so we are being very careful when we
coin these terms we spend a lot of time
thinking about those so we kept them in
a way that we don't need any more than
this sex
and we have asked this question to many
of many of these water
water diplomacy workshop attendees that
look do i need anything else
have we missed anything
tell us something that we missed
so maybe you will ask you the same
question have we missed any variables
that you need to include
to talk about what are conflicts those
are not there in this particular
figure
think of a variable or an actor or an
institution we are saying everything is
included here
maybe think about it and maybe before
the end of the semester you can let or
animation
these are big claims we're making say
look i think you don't need anything
else these six are good enough
because we have defined this
sufficiently broad so that you can go
and dig deeper into this
all right
so there's those essentially six now we
are saying that we can basically even
write it down in a little bit more
systematic we were talking about
variables and processes
that will come from the natural domain
actors and institutions will come from
societal domain
okay
and then you have values interests and
tools
and we go in that particular order so
values really so these you need to be
very very careful because what ends up
happening in most cases since i came
from a totally different domain when i
was doing my engineering stuff we were
particularly interested in tools
and then we basically started working
with larry and we found out under there
is something called interests and
positions
and then we need to talk about values
now we get into
really entangled mass
then
your problems policies and politics
what we argue that these things have to
come into place
you have a problem you have a politics
you have a politics unless these three
are aligned properly
you're not going to get a solution that
will be basically resilient and
sustainable just think about what
happened early between january 20th and
today is up till 20
7
just three months
in three months we have already
vaccinated about 200 million people
that was not the case in december
january what happened not nothing much
changed in the us few people changed in
white house
other than that most of the actors and
institutions are the same
so some of the problems politics and
politics has to align properly
if it does things can explode or things
can get totally basically out of control
so that's what the basically
big time thinking about is basically
this the difference between january 20th
and say april 27th
so this multiplicity of choices then
what it does really this essentially
fundamentally challenge this idea of
finding optimal solutions
this is where basically rita and weber
found in 1973
they were talking about that when you
have a social
problem
and this is couple we are calling them a
couple natural human system problem
to look for optimal solution is
impossible
so that's a recognition we must have
because this is the recognition at least
oftentimes we do not have when we are
coming from a technical domain from a
technical domain we want to find an
optimal solution very quickly and
optimal solutions are possible for a
well-structured systems
i can find out the optimal temperature
for my room
there is no problem because i can put
enough basically heating and air
conditioning and thermometer to get it
done
but if i want to do
optimal temperature for
city of boston it cannot be done because
city of boston is open
now things are coming back and forth
from all kinds from maybe from
connecticut or from maine or from canada
where cold air is coming in so i cannot
make this but on the other end my room i
can do it because room is bounded
this room is basically it has boundaries
it can be insulated it can be done
so if the system is bounded system is
well structured system is well defined
optimal solutions are okay
but in most natural systems they are not
in almost all couple systems is
impossible
when the natural system that human
systems are coupled then you cannot find
it then you need to be contingent in
context
then you say fine then what did i learn
if everything depend on the context and
everything is contingent why come to
school just go and do it
that's what i think will give you some
clue really with maybe with water
diplomacy and principal pragmatism how
that can be done although they're
contingent although they're contextual
so what are diplomacy then what is this
so scientific method i will say then in
general is objective so we'll talk about
little bit more closely so
policy and decision making is subjective
whether you like it or not that's what
it is
so whether your political bias is a very
biden versus trump admission you're
seeing that policy making decision
making so this is going to be subjective
whether we like it or
not then we're saying the scientific
facts are objective and this will be
maybe i think there are nuances that we
don't want to get into right now
social facts are subjective
so i'm making a sharp distinction
between these two things so there is a
scientific fact and there is a social
fact
when we talked about this idea of
alternative fact when people got
confused is that they were mixing it up
social facts are
basically there are alternative facts
scientific fact there is no relative
facts
if i take my temperature if you can find
it to be 98.4 it is 98.4
maybe with another thermometer you can
get 98.5 it cannot be 200 degrees
so that's a scientific fact i said this
is objective replicable reproducible
social fact would be how i feel about
the temperature
i may feel perfectly fine
and lady may feel perfectly hot
with the same temperature
although the thermometer is measuring
same temperature
how both of us feels is quite different
that's the social fact that simply
cannot be objectively defined and you
don't have to
but in decision making both are
important really
i just cannot use scientific fact to
make
decisions which will affect human beings
i can do this daily for machines
but when i bring in human beings when
they have emotion they have a
agencies they have
temptations i cannot use just scientific
effects and assume that it will work
so as a result now water diplomacy is
both subjective and objective
so that is essentially very problematic
in terms of implementation but this is
also very good because this is the way
you'll keep your job for next 50 years
because not anybody can do it that way
so that's the reason i think larry is
doing for 50 years i hope i can do it
too for another 20 years i'll tell you
really what to do
and that is exactly where i think the
brilliance and the ingenuity will come
in
that this is not easily separable
i cannot just take objective facts and
claims that i will be able to do water
management very well neither can i do
subjectively either so if i can combine
these two in some creative ways
you'll have credibility and you'll be
able to do it
yeah please can you repeat again the
example of the temperature which is to
to illustrate the uh the difference
between the subjective and objective
okay so just one second here let me see
here
so
objective facts would be i would say we
will go this into a little bit more
detail also objective fact i am defining
it very sharply so in my definition
objective fact is based on
scientific methods which are observable
it has to be observable
if it is not observable so observable by
how so then basically if you really want
to be very sharp you say we have five
senses
if these are not sensed by your five
senses it doesn't exist so i'll tell you
although i don't want to basically
make our friend
pinker
in other school on the red line he's a
cognitive psychologist in
at harvard delhi so he would tell you
really
everything else that you cannot sense or
can observe doesn't exist
so trust is no it doesn't exist
a trust is simply can it's not
measurable
he has a whole book called enlightenment
700 pages with hundreds of thousands of
graphs and he's showing that with
enlightenment we have basically done
remarkably well because in all measures
that he shows of course he's very
selective he is showing that everything
has improved like our infant modality
has improved our war has gone down
people dying from what has gone down
people dying out of hunger has gone down
so we are doing well
but in that book trust was not even
mentioned once
but he doesn't care really about trust
so for him
it's a scientific fact
unless it is observable it's not
scientific
social fact is now i feel bad
and we have too many people suffering
from mental disease right now
mental disease will become the most
pandemic really in next 20 years he
doesn't want he doesn't want to talk
about this
so for him those are subjective judgment
you figure it out
so that's the difference really thinks
those are not observable doesn't exist
so that's a very sharp it's a very crude
definition but that's the way i try to
do this also so i said this something
subjective is meaning that these are not
easily verifiable
but i do disagree with him that no they
exist
i may not be able to measure them
but they are real
and you may not be you he will say that
they are not even real
they're just a fiction of your
imagination
thank you very much thank you
so that brings us to this i think this
you like now
so here i want you to look at these two
pictures and i thought it was very nice
so there is a difference between myth
and fact
look at this first figure
and then
remember what this individual is doing
this individual now remembers myth
although you have given him 12 facts
so what is the problem
the problem is that our cognitive
ability to process information is not
really very good
so if you give me a lot of information
it's happening with coffee if you think
about coffee tealy
people are so confused
it's not that people are confused people
just simply cannot separate it out
because you are giving so many facts and
so many conflicting facts so ultimately
you remember the myth
that most likely i'll die
although the probability of you dying is
extremely low
even if you get it
on the other hand if you can give me
with some
carefully constructed facts
you do remember the fact
so the argument that i will make here is
that our challenge is to essentially
when i am trying to debunk some of this
myth or some of these social facts to
create scientific facts those are easily
digestible to the audience that i am
giving it to
but that's very very powerful because
otherwise i can keep talking about this
climate change a general public does not
understand what i'm talking about
as a result they think it's a hoax
so what does that mean really is this
when you're trying to replace a myth
from somebody's mind
you need to replace it by some facts
otherwise it will get
replaced by another myth
so the question is basically and the
politicians are extremely powerful
really
basically replacing myths
and meats are not really easily
discounted i don't
believe that myth can be easily taken
out they will be there the challenge is
to create meet those are little bit more
scientifically valid
if you can do this then i think you have
an alternative narrative otherwise you
don't have an alternative narrative you
have no way to make any
influence in the policy making and the
decision making
so that brings us to something that i
like is that
you remember you talked about what a
diplomacy framework we did not say that
it is a model it is not even a theory
right now so what is a framework
framework is something that is it's some
general ideas of general relationships
that gives you to address a particular
problem in a particular way
so that is the framework when the
framework gets tested over time so we
are doing it for many many years right
now so gradually it will become a theory
eventually it will become a model and
predictable
so right now we will put on water
diplomacy principle pragmatism as
framework this framework allows us to
explain those things in certain ways it
allows us to interfere in certain ways
when it becomes really a theory then you
guess basically
like evolution evolution is a theory
newton's law
is a law
neutral law is not a theory it's not a
framework
so there is a distinction between
framework theory and model
so model is at the level that you are
the newton's law so things are doesn't
matter really whether i mean boston or
i'm in brazil newton's law supplies
so that is what the difference is so if
you can
develop certain law those are context
independent
then you have a law so do i have a law
for water no i don't
i don't have a water diplomacy law
we have a water diplomacy framework
and that framework with time will
probably get
tested refined and get into theory and
hopefully into a model someday
so what are the principles the principle
that we are trying to use here in
principle pragmatic framework is this
objective scientific method
so we'll say that there is an objective
scientific method these five senses it
allows me to do certain things in
certain ways those will be independent
of context
giving our example of taking temperature
so temperature with a thermometer is a
measurable thing i can easily validate
this there is no ambiguity there
pragmatism comes in this sub-subjective
interpretation now
because
the example that i was giving that how i
feel about temperature is a subjective
interpretation
that interpretation should not be
confused with scientific methods
but i need both
i need scientific method i need also
subjective interpretation this is
exactly where water diplomacy comes in
that we just not only need scientific
methods we also need subjective
interpretation of the local values
local context
then if i can combine these two
we get principal pragmatism that is
subjective and objective
the same thing that we talked about our
water diplomacy
then we said okay like i think i don't
know you have talked about this we look
at world in various
i would say the simple ways we said that
there are only three types of systems
and our first job is to identify that
problem and that's the diagnosis and
characterization so it's
simple problems
but these causal relationships are well
understood
complicated is often ambiguous but not
easily identified but you can still
identify this
then you have complex problems
not easily identifiable only perceivable
in retrospect
so a good example of this would be like
flushing your toilet
you can go and buy basically a toilet
system from home depot for 100
it will work out very nicely no problem
bringing water to your home
from cuabon like about 50 miles away and
taking the water on the 16th floor of
your room and you get out you get warm
water that's a complicated system
i need lots of pumps and
pipes and then chlorination and heating
and so on
complex problem is the one then when we
created this quabon reservoir we have
also eliminated four villages
from guava because we wanted to create a
large reservoir
a lot of people have lost their homes
and they had to be bought out so was
this the right thing to do because you
are basically removing human beings from
four towns
for 200 years because boston has to grow
boston needed more water they needed to
create a co-op and deserve in 1920s so
they created this by eliminating four
villages
and there are still people complaining
that that was not the right thing to do
so that's a complex problem where you
have basically coupled a natural system
with human systems
now the system is in this case is
knowable and predictable
the flushing net oil is more or less
predictable
this is complicated but it's still more
or less predictable not always but
this one is most of the time
unpredictable
and emergent meaning that things will
just emerge that you have no idea really
it was going to come and from your
arsenic problem you have seen some of
this emergence we'll talk about a little
bit more
if you are to intervene in these systems
this will work with best practices
and this is where i think most of the
people got it wrong and i think we want
you to be very careful what we are
saying here is that
your best practices will apply very well
for simple systems
if you go into complicated system you
need some expert knowledge now and some
contextual knowledge
if you go into complex system now you
need something totally different
you need a synthesis of scientific facts
and social facts
you simply cannot use best practices
because there is no best practices for
complex systems
and although you will hear this time
often that give me a roadmap
no i cannot give you a roadmap
roadmap assumes that
i know the road so how do i know the
road i know the road because i have seen
it in the past so that means i am
assuming the past
will essentially be similar in the
future as well
if the future is little bit different
than the past
my past knowledge is not going to be
very useful
so i cannot have a roadmap
so to
hope for a roadmap to hope for a best
practices is an illusion we must abandon
to deal with complex problems
is that making sense
this is very important because we need
to make a distinction between these
three class of problems
your first job would be to essentially
decide which one is simple which one is
complicated which is complex
and then you cannot use the tool those
will be applicable for simple system
when the problem is actually complex or
vice versa
so if you assume that everybody is
working on
very
complex problems
each of these
cases you heard about
the beginning that people describe
they're they're all complex they may
have simple components within them
but basically
the conflicts and what's at the heart of
the conflicts are
complex it sounds from your description
like it's not really possible
to be
usefully prescriptive
in a situation in which the problems
you're dealing with
are
highly complex
do you think that's right or
do you know no
we're in trouble
at some level it is but at some level it
is not so let me see what i can explain
so the story that
what has to happen then is when you are
confronted with a problem like say we
are confronted with the problem of
ganges water treaty
so let's take this as an example
then we have to decidedly when we talk
about ganges water treaty what are we
talking about so if you ask me right now
i will say genji's water treaty should
primarily focus on the dry season flow
so now i'm trying to make the problem a
little bit sharper why dry season flow
in the wet season i have about 70 to 80
000 cubic meter per second of water flow
that is a flood season flood season
lasts for few weeks but it creates a
problem but that is a recurring
phenomenon
then in the dry season is almost about
eight to nine months that creates
significant problem both from water
availability for ecosystems to
irrigation to navigability so many many
things so i will focus on that part
then my
question would be okay so given that dry
season flow is only 4 000 as opposed to
80 thousand now what can i do
how do i basically resolve this
complexity of the problem now we have to
come up with delete with india and sit
down and see really what are the options
can i have
what are the options those are possible
so that we both can come up with some
options where we know we're not going to
get eighty thousand we need actually
twenty thousand we only have four
so how do i solve this problem
it's not easily resolvable then where
essentially this whole idea of mutual
value creation negotiation and
discussion has to come in
rooted in
scientific facts
that's basically where i think you can
think of really how do i get around this
mess because otherwise it becomes
such a complex problem that nothing can
be done
so are you saying that when you face a
complex problem
try to only work on part of it
no
uh what i would say that uh the prob uh
the approach would be problem driven
meaning that you have to define a
particular problem that you want to
solve so here i have defined the problem
with that i want to resolve the dry
season flow in the ganges that is my
problem right but isn't that really a
part of the larger problem of
managing the ganges it is it is no
question about it no question about it
and i don't think there is any way to
design tangle this
can you take it all separately no you
cannot so then what you do
so
at one extreme then you can think of
really that everything is interconnected
with everything else
if that is the case then you are in a
mess that mess simply cannot be
entangled right and you can argue that
no no you are essentially being
reductionist because you are trying to
reduce the problem to something that is
simpler
to some extent yes but
what we want to be careful really when
i'm defining the problem for the dry
season
i don't want it to be a reductionist
problem that basically it will not get
affected by flood
so i need to be careful really the
the lesser the dry season is eight
months
these eight months will affect it by
other four months too
how that is the question if they are
cleanly separable
then it's easy but they are not cleanly
separable they will not be
so this is where the complexity will
come i don't think how hard we try you
will be able to go in that's the reason
scientific method is important because
you need to keep this idea of
experimentation valid
so you observe you ask questions you
hypothesize you experiment analyze
conclude and keep doing this
then you go
here so i think with this i don't think
we need to code this because this is
more into
recognize that basically there is no
panacea here so if there is no panacea
then what is there what i am saying that
we need to be precise in diagnosing the
problem
so so here the whole approach that we
are trying to take is that it is a
problem driven approach it is not a
theory driven approach so i have a
problem
the that problem is to solve dry season
water problem in bangladesh or in india
not to do this tonight so that is my
diagnosis of the problem now what are
the facets of the diagnosis
what the aspect do i need to do
is it really to keep a calcutta port
navigable or is it really to stop salt
water intuition in sundarban in
bangladesh
or both are important if both are
important then how do i try to see
really given the limited amount of water
that i have can i do both
if i cannot then do i have other options
what if i use
groundwater can i use groundwater in a
year and next year basically i have more
rain it gets filled with groundwater
also i cannot use it forever because it
will get depleted
so those are the type of discussion that
has to happen so
the precisely the point with complex
system is that complex systems will not
allow you to give a solution that is
static
it will give you a solution given that
particular problem given that time and
space scale
then what we need to be careful is that
we monitor
and we keep adapting to the changing
situations
so that brings up this we have to
embrace complexity with humility there
that is not that basically i'm going to
give you solution that you have it there
is no prescription that is universal i
cannot do it
i'm just being very honest and blunt but
at the same time i'm giving you a
framework that framework will allow you
to do things in certain ways
then you
think in a systematic way what does that
mean that means that you try to define
what your system boundary is
what are the nodes and links in that
system so that you when you get this
spaghetti diagram
what are the notes and links that
create this spaghetti diagram and that
is
understandable and systematically
manageable
then you say okay i diagnose and
prescribe so i'm saying you need to
prescribe so what do you how do you
prescribe them the way you prescribe
by understanding the capacity
of the system
as well as the constraints that system
imposes on you
what that means really
the capacity and constant for the ganges
between bangladesh india will be quite
different
if you are trying to do it for the nile
between egypt and ethiopia
so the challenge here is that you have
diagnosed the problem now you have to
give in to give some prescription that
prescription must be consistent
with the capacity that your system has
and that capacity can involve basically
from human capital to basically actual
assets of money to cultural values and
everything else
but not all of them are important at
a giving given time
the challenge for us to get as water
diplomat is to find out what those are
and try to define that subset
otherwise this set is very large
you can go to the ganges and assume that
look ganges water is probably one of the
most polluted water in the world
but it is the most holy water for hindus
in india
so i cannot basically start questioning
that cultural value
that has to be taken into account
so that is the capacity and constant the
system is imposing on me
then i said that there is no no nasia
so let's be clear about this that there
is no simple generalizable best
practices
then i said okay
excuse me shuffy when you say
diagnose and prescribe
using capacity and constraints
you don't mean that you can't enhance
the capacity
with resources from outside the system
right no i don't i think very good point
no question so i think we have to be
exactly i think we we need to bring
another
capacity is not fixed
capacity can be enhanced capacity can be
reinforced even i think can be built and
even can be
taken as an outside energy
so world bank can create more basically
can put in money
absolutely
i think i need to be a little bit more
careful there
it's not that so no let's not assume
that the system capacitance constants
are fixed
so the question is do we need anything
else
because i'm also teaching this similar
class at top so i think so we did post
this question so
and i'm asking maybe you guys also that
okay so if is this a more or less
general abstract level of things that we
need to do
to start addressing the problem then
we'll get into very quickly our
arsenic problem the how this can be
applied in real time
so maybe i think i don't know how much
time do we have animation
i think we have about 10 or 15 minutes
okay so yeah all right so let's do the i
think maybe i'll just go into this
could you could you just go back one for
a minute to the diagram to the list you
had
you said is in the question marks at the
end is that
is that insufficient is that complete do
we need anything else like one question
you read i think i need to
use this
my uneasiness with that list
is that if you're going to
act
adaptively
if you're going to
continue to review and change what
you're doing
you need to have the institutional
capacity
to do that just to build
the
institutional
capacity
to think and act systematically to build
the capacity to
adapt adapt uh act adaptively
and so the person who's
talking about taking action
i think
needs to think about the institutional
design
but the process that makes this list
possible and that itself becomes an item
on the list sure good point
any other thoughts
all right i think let's see whether we
can
so essentially that what we are arguing
so i hope i convince you that there is
no established methodology exists to
resolve complex problems because these
problems are not deterministic not
random so that means you cannot use
classical physics or you cannot use
statistical mechanics to do this
then
at the same time these problems can
neither be fully explored by the
positivist meaning this hypothesis
testing type of framework that i was
arguing that with five senses
so you cannot just use scientific
methods
nor can you use just interpretations
so it's not that basically you can use
either or methods really so you cannot
use purely scientific method you cannot
use purely subjective ethnographic
matters to address these problems
what then you have to do really is some
way to basically combine your scientific
facts and social facts
so that's what is all about and if you
look at the paper that i sent you to
read this arsenic contamination problem
essentially tries to do this
is to explain the problem from a
scientific facts perspective
then use the understanding meaning the
social facts to actually address the
problem so what that means really so
let's go back in this thing you've seen
before you will not go here so i go here
so i use an illustrative case
illustrative case is that
it can support a theory
so the arsenic contamination problem is
used here as an illustrative case
meaning that it illustrates that it's a
complex problem but it does not really
provide any validation of the theory
but we have also used it as an extended
case meaning that if i take this case
and i look at all the features what i
see really here is this is a couple
natural and human system problem
in this couple natural human system
problem when i intervene
it gives rise to emergent properties
and then it becomes a complex problem
so that means i can use this to show
really when you have this type of
coupling
you will expect this type of things to
happen
so now if you take actually what
happened then there so you have
basically bangladesh has decided that
they will promote groundwater use as a
case study that we are using it here
there are two policy goals
they want to increase agricultural
productivity and reduce infant mortality
so these were the policy goals they
wanted to do
a very sharp very well defined easily
measurable
and then you go and then you see this
so this is where essentially now if you
try to link all this different component
different variables processes now you
see this is a mess
and this mess really is not new and this
is not even our mess i think many people
have created this type of mess they call
the system diagram and interaction
diagram whatever and we are saying that
this is really
so old because it doesn't allow me to do
anything
i just totally get
paralyzed
so it's not going to work because things
are interconnected we understand that
part the question then is becomes how do
you diagnose or sharply define the
problem that not all of these links and
notes are equally important
only some are
the question is which are
see in the case of like diocesan flow we
gave you an example relief that is what
we want to do so that's a
much
simpler definition of the problem with
the interconnections and
interdependencies those will be needed
once you have that
then you can go here so if you look at
what bangladesh has done they wanted to
have two policy goals and these were
achieved really with tremendous success
it has increased agricultural
productivity decreased infant mortality
agricultural productivity has gone up by
almost hundred percent
infant modality was the lowest in south
asia
so in those
terms it was very good really very
basically successful story from 1960 to
almost 1980s
then what you started seeing there
arsenic contamination emerges now
in 1960 they did not expect that arsenic
contamination will come
the difficulty they have created they
have not measured so they were not
following it so they were not really
monitoring the progress they are not
being adopted they did not care
so as a result it emerges even that
emergence did not really lead to any
action it took another 15 years
before on the
the day first the arsenic was detected
in water
then to actually create something at the
government never it took 15 years why
did it take that long
so that's what basically the system
failed
then you have taken interventions which
left even more unintended emergence
if you remember really you looked at
this basically they put red and green
wells now the villages that had red
wells now have problems with basically
girls getting married because they have
a stigma
so you've created a social stigma by
creating a solution that you wanted to
do because you wanted to let people know
that there is
this
well is
red meaning it has high arsenic
concentration so where did that come
from what i argue that basically this
was also really
what we learned from this this was a
theory driven causality-based reasoning
where did that come from so that really
came
from if you
know the story of
cholera in london in 1854
in jon snow
found out that he was an epidemiologist
he found out that there is a cholera
outbreak in london and they cannot find
out what is going on
so he did a very systematic way of
finding out who has cholera where the
drinking water is coming from and he
found out well
and he went and basically started
that well done
cholera went away
so that is basically my theory or by
basically scientific knowledge that i
used in bangladesh also without
understanding anything else so i
basically went and started painting
everything red
because there's no need and it stopped
cholera so if i do this arsenic will be
stopped yes it will be the only
difficulty there is that this is rural
bangladesh number one i have over 10
million wealth right now and not one so
as a result really my theory doesn't go
with actually what is happening on the
ground
so we got into serious mess and that
took another 20 years to unfold
so
what would happen in a principal
pregnancy approximately what you want to
do really you want to find out the
problem different question so the
question was that really okay so i have
infant mortality problem in bangladesh
so to solve that infinite modality
problem i found out the quickest
solution what was the quickest solution
the
dig some shallow wells it's cheaper is
quicker fine and we've done that and
that is perfectly fine what was missing
there is that they did not monitor
really the progression of this
they just assumed that it's a simple
solution it will stay forever
if they have monitored this they would
have found out long ago
that's why basically this problem-driven
question with hypothesis is consistent
with observed signals
i need to keep observing the system as
it evolves
if i can do this then i have an approach
that is more or less functional
so to summarize that basically what we
need to do really we need to first find
out
a very sharp definition of the problem
that we want to address
then
find out whether is this a simple
problem complicated problem or a complex
problem
then find out if it is a complex problem
that what is the complexity coming from
is the complexity coming from the
scientific unknown or is it coming from
the social fact those are alternatives
then try to synthesize these two
then design an intervention with some
basically targeted metric that this is
what i want to do and then monitor this
as you go along then you could be
adaptive
and find out a solution that will
basically be resilient and change also
over time
there is no universal solution
so if you want message you want to take
i think that would be that there is no
universal generalizable solution for
complex systems
complex systems will bring even more
problems once you try to solve them by
the time you have solved them you have
given rise to another set of problems
and this is also nothing new really this
has been done in with ladies department
for many years from like shawn to other
people they have talked about these
problems almost 50 years ago
that the idea of really when you're
trying to
do these social problems really by the
time you solve the problem you have
given rise to another set of problems
so the challenge is to essentially be
very
aware of that problem nature will change
and if it does really how do i detect
them early on
so that i can be adaptive and
act accordingly
we'll stop here
so
do you have any
final question to topic
what are your thoughts about the
enabling conditions between india and
pakistan and the uh on on
taking up their divisions and then this
water treaty
enable conditions should be those will
remain three what you want to do really
hopefully i think is that
what are the
main issues of contentions right now
that needs to be discussed
because i have not following recently
about the industry
what would be good i think for if you
can identify one or two things that
both countries are in disagreement with
what is that really so i can give you
one example for example for brahmaputra
is that what i followed recently is
say for example india is claiming that
china is holding all the water and then
it will create problem
physically that is not true
because the amount of water that is
coming from brahmaputra for china even
if china we did this study with
domination with another chinese student
we had even if they decide to keep all
the water
in china it will have no impact in india
although they are making that claim so
this is essentially a social media they
want to create that yeah china is
creating problem
but these are not based on facts
so what you want to do really with indus
to find out is it possible to
find some very sharp scientific effects
those are observable like one example i
use with bangladesh in india for the
ganges
even if i give all the water to india
in the dry season
india will still not be able to
basically make their calcutta for
navigable during the dry season
so that means this is a non-starter why
we start fighting with this try to find
something else then
although of course it is clear serious
problem maybe india keeps all the water
in the dry season
but even if bangladesh decided i'll give
you everything
still you will not solve the problem
so that means you need alternative
sources now
that part has not been explored
before we finish i just want to thank
shafiq again
um we and i've worked together a long
time on this and i'm always learning
something new each time i hear him
present this material
so thank you for taking the time chefy
to meet with the class and for sharing
your ideas
um and thank you for having such good
ideas yeah so thank you very much
i think no i don't want to embarrass
larry larry has been an inspirational
mentor
so because many of the things that i
discussed today i did not know about
maybe 15 years ago when i started up so
we have been talking for a long time now
so yeah
if you look at this guy you say you need
10 000 hours siri to develop any set of
expertise so between both of us we
probably spend more than ten thousand
hours now
hopefully we have some level of at least
understanding or expertise
yeah also yeah
from
our side yeah for everybody in the class
right the other people in this class are
potentially
the person you'll
find yourself coming back to and working
with
uh when sharpike and i we did not know
each other when we first
encountered some overlap in our
interests and
we just kept creating opportunities to
exchange our thoughts and sort of
animesh then gets added to the
mix and now
extends both of our ideas and our work
and his own work
so everybody in the
class should imagine
that you
it's it's through these interactions
with your colleagues
that you shape and sharpen your ideas so
um
i think thank you okay
so for the class i think i have a
challenge for you since you did not
share much of your thoughts maybe you're
too shy so think about the
arsenic paper that you read i want you
to find out at least one hole
or one thing that you found it this is
really outrageously
stupid it's not going to work so i
gave that same challenge to my students
also so there are few things that i
have issues i did not share those with
you but i will not tell you right now i
think but i want you to see really what
like
larry raised something very
interesting here if the institutional
mechanism is not there if the capacity
is
constant it's not going to work so we
need to refine that but are there
anything else you see really in terms of
making it operational
what we are saying that see at one point
i said the complex systems you don't
have generalizable solutions you don't
have any
prescription but then we are giving you
a prescription too
so the line is very subtle here
but at the same time i don't see a way
around it
so the question is basically how do i
bring in these ideas of principles of
scientific methods which are more
replicable more
reproducible with the social facts which
are
going to be continuously subjective
continuously contentious
but at the same time this has to be made
so that's why basically what are the
hiccups or what are the
binding constant that will essentially
let it fail
if you can think of one or two ideas
that will be good or
maybe an example that you have seen in
your real life
where you try to apply this and see did
not work
he wants you to be a white hat hacker of
his work
yep
that'll be good
find find
programming problems
exactly so if i define the whole and
then yeah
that would be very nice
that's the way ideas get
otherwise
yeah because you get stuck today yeah
yeah and also apart from that i even if
you have
your own uh specific issue regarding
water diplomacy that can be
related to the theory that tropic
mentioned you can also write him an
email so that yeah sure please please
feel free
all right i'm gonna disappear but thank
you so much thank you very much
look forward to the presentation
starting next week okay
all right bye yeah thank you thank you
you